on monogamy
i would really
like to hear
i would really like to hear you talk
about what your views on monogamy are
um okay so i spoke about this a few
times and
there is a social scientist by the name
of robert p barash who wrote a book
called out of eden
and in that book he
basically he basically said that human
beings are not wired to be monogamous
um
um he was saying that
this is his his argument that human
beings are more closer to apes
and apes aren't monogamous like a
certain percentage of apes are not
monogamous
and so when
quote-unquote cheating happens
it's because of a biological and
a wiring let's say that a lot of men
have and he was also saying that
prior to um western colonization of
the world
most people whether you go to
africa asia middle east were living in
some kind of poliginous or polygamous
type situation
and it's only the coming of the western
civilization where everyone said okay
one man for one woman whereas generally
before that
people were living in
you know
multiple type relationship scenarios so
it's like yeah when when he put it like
that i was like oh okay cool because
a lot of women now they wonder why you
know men are cheating men are cheats man
of dogs blah blah and it's like
well
maybe they're not wired that way and i'm
not saying that because i've been in
monogamous relationships
i'm not saying that men cannot be
monogamous
i'm saying that probably a lot of them
are not
but what is happening is that because
i believe women have been sold the dream
of monogamy house kids
white picket fence
my husband mike they've been like that
dream of like prince charming has been
sold
in this society
a lot of
people don't understand why a lot of men
are doing like doing this kind of stuff
and i'm not making excuses for men doing
it i'm just saying a lot i think the
conversation needs to be had because i
think
um
a lot of men are lying to themselves and
also lying to their women because i'm
telling you as a man men know whether
they're monogamous or not
right they know when they get into a
relationship whether they're gonna cheat
on this woman or not oh
you know what i mean so
if they know
can a woman handle being told you know
what i do
because don't get me wrong men love
their woman they can say you know what
baby i love you i want to be for the
rest of my life
but
if the rest of my life is the next 50
years
do you think your vagina is the only
vagina i'm going to see for that next 50
years
how realistic is that that's what i'm
asking like how realistic is that do you
know what i mean like
i ask a question of course so if you're
saying that so then
what if the man were to be like you know
able to be in like an open relationship
would it be i mean you'd have to say
like oh the woman can also do the same
as well can't you um i think so this is
my personal opinion now this is not like
anything but i think when it comes to
women and
that
the
the
murky water on that is
if she was to get pregnant who's whose
baby would it be
yeah do you know what i mean like who's
whose child would it be
would it be the guy's child would it be
that guy's child would you would it
would a man just say okay cool it
doesn't matter it's from him
and it's going to be all of our child
men ain't really built that way i think
there's a reason why you know lions when
they take over a pride they kill all the
children
of
the previous women
it's like because it's like no i want to
start my thing like i don't care about
those like they literally kill the
babies of that thing they're like i want
to start my thing and it's like men
generally are wired differently for
women i think
i just think it's different i don't know
i think it's just hard to compare animal
like mammals because like i would say
like humans were like
a little more intelligent you know yep
like emotionally
and just like common like i don't know
how to say the word like common sense we
have a little bit more conscious they're
more conscious of animals yeah
so
i wouldn't be like oh you know because
like a
what is a family of wine kills like
another person's child then that means
like oh like no but how many of you have
been cheating how many have you been
cheating on
you've all been cheated on
[Music]
well because we like a small percentage
like if um it's like if you ask 80 of
women what they want in a man they list
20 of men sometimes even less right so
like for example only 15 ish percent of
guys are over six foot like i don't know
the exact number so if you want a guy
over six five six two i'm good
and let's say you add like you know
money on top of that it's like a smaller
and smaller percentage of guys and then
you know chemistry vibes whatever it is
yeah whatever and then you realize that
you're like competing for like a very
small yeah
and that small group of men understand
that they're being competed for right
and so their options are boundless
and it's like if you're going for those
kind of guys who have boundless options
it's like
do you think they're not going to try
and take one of those options at one
point in time like do you really think
so
and i'm not saying that it's right or
wrong by the way i'm not i'm just saying
it happens i have a follow-up question
do you do you believe women are
hypergamous of course they are okay
so
hypergamy is just means like
i would say the best way to describe it
is we want to get the best possible like
maybe we can get yeah we want to date up
so then by that like logic do you think
if we if i have a family and i can do
better
within my husband i should leave my
husband because by nature i'm
hypergamous i don't think you should um
sorry excuse me i don't think you should
leave your husband who you've made a
commitment to
just because you're hypergamers so
then would you say the same thing for
men you shouldn't cheat on your wife
that you've made the commitment to just
because yeah yeah i would i would i
actually would i think if you make a
commitment okay
you are bound by that commitment okay i
believe that however i i think a lot of
people make commitments not being honest
yeah and that's why yeah that's true
that is why
the cheating happens and i think if a
guy came to be like you know what baby i
love you we've been together for this
long blah blah but you know at some
point in time i'm just i'm just gonna do
something right
that's more honest but you as a woman
have to now decide whether you're okay
with that and that's being honest what
men do is like no baby you're gonna be
arrested the rest of my life is with you
and no one else it's like stop lying
why are you lying
so i think yeah if you make a commitment
and you sign a contract you should be
upheld to that contract i think i think
many people sign that contract
and i think that's why it's so important
to like know who you are i think a lot
of men think oh women need to find
themselves i think that's like more like
stereotype like women need to understand
themselves know themselves but men need
to know who they are yes in order to
make such a commitment like know what
you're know who you are as a person
before you make a come like i can commit
to you but you can't because as a nobody
no if he wants to he will but like
to a certain extent it's not in their
character like no but you know
women think that a man committing or not
committing this having such a couple man
they are like you can still be like a
man that's okay with monogamous
relationship but maybe or not maybe you
prefer polyamorous relationships and
maybe you just don't understand that but
you're committing to that knowing you're
still going to be right in your face
right but if you actually understood
yourself studied yourself you actually
put in the time and levels of commitment
to being like you know what this is who
i am and then knowing what you can give
to a woman that's a different thing
but to know to not actually fully put in
that work and then be like you know what
baby i can commit to like i know you
can't like